[Musique]
c'est un événement qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne c'est un événement
qui est dédié à l'innovation avec un
focus particulier sur les régions cette
année le focus particulier c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'innovation de rupture
tirs des innovations qui apporte une
vraie discontinuité un vrai et en large
et élargissement par exemple les
applications d'une technologie
un premier objectif bien sûr qu'ils
aient de kate se rencontrer et de
travailler discuter de l'échangé des
bonnes des bonnes pratiques de définir
d'analyser les manques de notre
dispositif d'innovation active en europe
et d'essayer de définir des
améliorations par exemple ce qu'on
appelle le scale up c'est à dire la
capacité à faire accélérer des startups
en industrialisant les innovations pour
leur permettre véritablement de créer de
la valeur économique à l'échelle du
continent européen
la première journée sera à dominante
institutionnels donc il s'agira de faire
un petit peu le bilan des dispositifs
existants d'analyser les menaces les les
opportunités nous aurons des
intervenants donc des grandes
institutions européennes également du
ministère la deuxième journée on aura
plutôt une logique de zoom avec des
ateliers de travail en parallèle donc
ils se pencheront sur des sujets des
points d'amélioration bien identifiée du
dispositif européen
les participants de oued dans la
troisième et dernière partie troisième
et dernière journée de l'événement iront
visiter des laboratoires et des centres
de recherche pour voir sur le terrain la
traduction de ses efforts en faveur de
l'innovation
[Musique]